[Music]
yeah was a bit late hello and welcome to
this video playing Smitty 77 I mean I
like the Sicilian with white really so
let's do it you get you get the art
player really has no clue what he has he
has his some line here worked out mmm he
knows his stuff
hmm Quincy's tone
I think it cannot be bad to get the
Queen to see six instead of the bishop
which is happening a lot in this line
okay
so it would be very natural to get the
bishop to G - okay must be really bad to
ever think about stuff just for a second
but anyway
[Music]
it's a direct way to punish this we
should have form probably not leading to
to too much
we put some pressure on that poem
it's not it's not really all that
fantastic I thought that I would have a
little bit more here but it is really
not a lot
and we can always take and put a knight
on to d5 which is some young very sodium
you secure the back rank at some point
in this game yeah it's very difficult to
make any headway here some endings would
be quite good like if he takes on c4
with mine like if he takes on c4 now
this would be would be quite good but
it's probably not happening I have two
against one so he shouldn't take on C
form he's got can play many things that
wouldn't hurt his position much
and g3 was just to prevent Knight f4 he
does take yeah unless he has a very
concrete idea about this this is just
not good yeah maybe I wants to he wants
to double him against him like rook c8
ma'am I cannot really move this and a4
there is night eggs before so not really
doing much yeah so this is probably okay
still okay for black
but Nietzsche trade trade one trading
one rook exactly one would be nice and
then get the King closer and start to
push the pawns this is something that
could work but it's really not clear how
I can ever get this get this going
so yeah I can still not move the bishop
unfortunately King tiiime it will
probably check me but maybe you just see
last night he doesn't what what is he
doing you really don't get this so he
lost me a pass a it's really odd this is
a good ending now for white let's see
check here
[Music]
not sure if I'm winning after the trade
unfortunately from him if I get in five
and I'm winning I even know he will not
trade is the thing he will not take but
okay he cannot take on v6 I think that
that's not going to work
and now I can contrive try to improve my
position even further just wonder how
exactly five won't cut it scrolling them
and I have to go to Sephora I need I
need further entry squares is the thing
yeah but now I can push the King back
like somewhere
King the a true got7 King here King F a
droopy six and if he moves the rook I go
physics as well just like I said I have
seven seconds the only thing that is
going to be a problem
mmm never stupid I mean maybe still
enough but not happy about it
hey well some time a day I still win
here worth taking a 6 but still ok I
have no clue about the way a plate is
ending what this was all about if we if
we start here yeah so if he does not
take on Safari is never going to be a
problem but ok it so is ok to take our
leave oh but here you can also just stay
and again I think it's ok for him but I
did absolutely don't understand why you
not just stay here I mean you just have
to do nothing a black can never play for
a win that would be quite ridiculous to
think that so you just have to stay and
this is I don't know you know why go to
a four I mean you never want to take on
c5 it's still not not a big thing but
like here this I don't I don't get that
I must be enormous to bury him and I'm
almost certain that I had some way to go
into Kinghorn inning that was winning
but yeah here here I don't think I'm
winning because I cannot really enter
the pollution so keeping keeping this
here was ok and here f5 was winning ok
this is a forceful move this King defies
okay this is nice this is nice it's
something that you will will definitely
go for if you have time but I had no
time so this is
again f5 I didn't see a five so there's
a the engine gave me like a couple of
blunders but the blunders were not
seeing at five I can break him and I
think it should win anyway but yeah five
is possible and it's possible to see
yeah also I mean it just gives me the
desired entry to the position I was not
having time and this is often leading to
not the best play quite clearly but at
least I don't think I screwed it up
completely guarantee he overstepped the
time mm yeah after hook c8 took a six it
should be winning the NC poll are too
much
okay yes thanks for watching